my word homes it is staggering
I'm not acquainted with a progress of
modern scholarship but this collection
is enormous what a treasure trove of our
culture yes yes what come along like a
fellow we have worked yeah
what is your force here crime of course
Connery yeah the library this library
and every library Watson serious crime
murder Clarence Holmes who's being
murdered the books Watson the books
forgive me
perhaps murder is too strong a word but
the books are being killed destroy
destroy
I say Holmes that serious charge you
certainly this very sir
it's happening now in fact countless
numbers of books are being destroyed
every single day that's charity we want
to do such a thing to discover that
lesson it's why we are here come let us
go to the scene of the crime
put heavens it's even worse than I
suspected watch yourselves
there's only here with shelves of books
I don't see any cars for your alarm I
know neither you nor most other people
that's part of the problem say how's it
there's one that should interest you Oh
allow me Watson yes monograph on
alkaline toxicology perhaps it could be
of use to me even after your assault on
it really Holmes I didn't lady yes
Watson I fear it is so not with intent
of course but assorted you did
nevertheless just as those to whom this
collection is entrusted also wreak havoc
upon these many volumes and yet
prevention of such damage is simplicity
itself if those who work with books
would only adhere to an axiom of mine
which one is a doubt the little things
are infinitely with the most important
and so it is with presentation let's
look into the matter more closely
this section of books what do you deduce
from it Watson well it looks normal to
me but I shouldn't like to use it again
for fear of repeating my offence
understandable but it is not only you
who has created the problem observe the
shelves this shelf which you first
attacked the books are simply not
supported properly in an upright
position
now the shelving is correct
each book supported vertically by its
neighbouring volume and the bookend
notice they are snug but loose enough to
allow removal of a volume in yes I see
now what about this next shelf Watson
well these books certainly won't fall
over as the others do that's true but
the Shelf is too tight the bookend has
been used to disadvantage a slight
loosening and the book can be removed
without damage and this shelf is a
potential disaster the books are just
perched there precariously but by
returning them to their correct position
they are now properly supported and
present neither hazard nor hindrance to
removal
this project has been crammed into a
space too small it needs to be shelved
the long way in to save it from
permanent damage Jolyon house where
think you would but it must go in spine
down notice the volume next to it shows
four edge down see how gravity pulls the
text block out of its case if a volume
is too tall to be shelled vertically so
let's find out so the text block does
not pull away from the cover Helms this
book has been shelved incorrectly yes
Watson I also observed her doing so it's
obvious the problem can be solved merely
by teaching people how to properly place
books back on the shelf that's only the
half of it my good man correct shelving
and storage are crucial but one must
allow for actual careful handling of the
books is that toxicology Joe Harris is
the one with the recently torn head cap
no need to look abashed Watson if proper
shelving techniques have been applied
then this simple procedure can be
followed to remove the desired volume
gently push the volumes on either side
back grasp the book you want firmly at
the center of the spine and pull it from
the shell thus no damaging strain is
exerted on the weaker vulnerable
portions of the binding after removal of
course the empty space is closed up by
pushing the bookend snug to maintain
vertical support for the remaining
volumes on the shelf did you know our
lat aren't elementary my dear Watson
elementary but what if the books are
packed a little too tightly or if the
desired volume is at the end
the shelf how can the volume be removed
without causing damage to the cover or
binding structure mountains sea perhaps
perhaps what if one were to press down
on the pages on the top of the book
choke the book forward and then grasp
the spine that's the capital Watson you
surpassed yourself yes indeed this
alternative method will serve the same
protective function for safe removal of
books if the preservation is quite
simple and now soon please be good
enough to hand me that volume up there
this one yes that large folio volume
calf all the right procedures but you
didn't give yourself an opportunity to
apply them a step stool will give you an
even chance to remove the volume and
maintain support for those that remain
seems like a good idea when reshelving a
volume as well well is your work here
finished then almost there still remains
several secondary problems
let us aim toward that area there
I say Holmes
this one looks as though the same chap
loaded it as did the bookshelf at there
indeed and I dare say it will topple
over at some point it's so badly loaded
it should have been loaded using the
same principles I outlined for regular
shelves just as has been done with this
one aha Holmes what is it yet another
dangerous condition welcome these
shelves were properly done here this
empty soda can and the remains of a meal
scattered across here in medical school
sometimes we spend hours is the same
thing with these students here one of
them just didn't have time to go out for
dinner good heavens
I'm not totally without feeling but
preservation demands constant vigilance
it may not be possible to prevent
deterioration caused by environmental
conditions pollution or other factors
beyond the library's control but those
conditions that can be controlled must
be controlled yes I can sympathize with
wanting to satisfy one's hunger pangs
but not with the damage caused by doing
so oh really
Holmes it may be a little untidy Watson
eating and drinking in the stacks brings
bugs and roaches just as surely as ants
follow picnic and once insects are here
in the stacks their next meal is the
paper and the glue in the books totally
destroying whatever they attack here an
example of such damage
and look at that fella over there not
only has he brought his beverage into
the stats if he spills it the book will
be soaked and probably destroyed even if
the liquid is only water this library
employee should be practicing proper
preservation techniques how to announce
by reminding anyone she sees eating or
drinking in the stacks to please delay
their refreshment in order to help
preserve the very books they are here
perusing that's the best kind of
preservation Watson not only preventing
the sorts of damage caused by improper
shelving and book handling but also
trying to discourage the library's users
from causing damage by their
carelessness here let me show you how
simple that can be
even here Watson a little attention to
preservation can eliminate yet another
source of damage to the books here
Holmes but all I see is people returning
books to the library precisely and some
of those books may spend months in the
stacks before they see the light again a
paper clip left in a book for that
length of time can rust and permanently
mark the pages as can a rubber band or
some other bookmark left too long in one
place but if the circulation Kirk were
to make a brief observation of each
volume as it is returned and remove the
offending items the eventual damage
would be prevented preservation is as
simple as even this but enough of that
oh boy we can leave now
but homes aren't we going to solve this
crime we already have Watson I know who
is killing the boss Oh everyone Watson
the people who use the library and the
people who work in the library all
people who come in contact with books
but who failed to give sufficient
thought to the consequences of their
actions that's the problem what's the
solution
preservation bitch is had more than 7
percent solution news yes of course
Watson if we are to keep books alive
preservation is the 100% solution hmm
preservation hmm come along Watson we've
got to go it's time preservation